bon ça
mais ce toit
[Musique]
bracke prépare tes affaires on doit
changer de corps ouais
il était à ma recherche parce que je
suis une fille ouais
je suis la dernière fille ondes
il est vrai et venait de naître quand
tout est arrivé
il faudra que tu la protèges
keira vous rappelez sans toi
messi
ouvrir sur l'autre
je connais personne à part toi
ouais moi quand le reste du monde ça me
plaît oui moi aussi qu'on peut aller
voir ja kaka ya même délit regarde ça on
peut rester ici
[Musique]
c'est bon
faire boire du parlera soin de moi
d'accord tu lui diras j'aurais voulu la
voir grandir de dieu
durée ce qui se passe
[Musique]
sortez de là
je m'appelle
ouais
fin de l'histoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]